I want to turn to
the new
classified documents that the FBI found
at the president's house in Delaware.
It was a 13 hour search
that happened on Friday.
It's just the latest
revelation of the president
having classified items
that he shouldn't have.
You've been in Congress for 40 years.
You've handled classified material
for a lot of those years,
probably most of them.
How concerned are you about this?
Well, I'm concerned.
There's a standard that we follow
when it comes to members of Congress
and classified information.
The door to my office is closed.
The person who presents
the document to me
takes it out of a locked briefcase,
hands it to me, and watches as I read it
when I finish reading it.
He takes it back
and puts it in the briefcase
and leaves the scene.
I mean, that's
how carefully we review these documents.
To think
that any of them ended up in boxes
in storage, one place to the other
is just unacceptable.
But having said that,
let me make this point clear.
Joe Biden has said from the start,
we are going to be totally transparent
about this.
Let the chips fall where they may.
I'm going to open my home voluntarily.
To a search,
not the first search,
I'm sure, of his offices at home.
He has shown total cooperation
in this effort.
That is a sharp contrast
to President Trump.
Well, I want to.
Speaking of former President Trump,
I want to play something
that you said last year
about the classified documents found
at his Mar a Lago resort.
It's an outrage.
It is a
literal outrage
for the president
to take this important information
down to his home in Florida.
And then store it in a closet
with traffic.
People back and forth in
his resort and golf course is an outrage.
Is it also an outrage
for the current president
to have what appears to be multiple
classified documents
in multiple locations
At its heart, the issue is the same.
Those documents should not have been
in the personal possession
of either Joe Biden or Donald Trump.
But what happened and followed from
it is significantly different.
Donald Trump
defied those who knew
the documents were in place
and ultimately led to involuntarily
a court order
and a search of his Mar a Lago hotel
resort to find out
how many documents were there.
Contrast that with Joe
Biden,
embarrassed by the situation
as he should have been He
he invited the government agencies
in to carefully
look through all the boxes
he had accumulated.
It's a much different approach.
It is outrageous that either occurred,
but the reaction by the former president
and the current president
could not be in sharp contrast.
They are they are very different.
No question about that.
Having said that, you are a politician.
You've been around for a while
and you understand
how these things play out.
Do you fear that because of that,
the current president has kind of lost
a high ground on this notion
of classified information
being where it shouldn't be
Well, of course,
let's be honest about it.
When that information is found,
it diminishes the stature of any person
who is in possession of it
because it's not supposed to happen,
whether it was
the fault of a staffer or turning.
It makes no difference.
The elected official bears
ultimate responsibility.
And we have to worry
since this new group
that has taken over control
of the House of Representatives
has promised us
endless investigations confrontations,
impeachments and chaos.
What's going to happen?
I only have one word for those
who are dubious as to
whether that will happen.
And the word is Benghazi.
How long did we spend
going through
Benghazi hearings
in the Republican
controlled House in the past?
Now, imagine the mega Republicans
and what they're setting out to do.
I'm sure that they're going
to have investigations
to our hearts delight.
I want to turn to the debt ceiling, sir.
The White House insists
they are not going to negotiate
with Republicans
who are demanding spending cuts
in exchange for raising the debt limit
so America doesn't default on its debt.
Do you think the
president should negotiate
No, absolutely not.
Let's get to the bottom line here.
Those who are posing for holy pictures
as budget balancers,
the mega Republicans
should note one important fact.
Almost 25% of all of the national debt
accumulated over the history
of the United States.
230 years
was accumulated
during the four years of Donald Trump.
So the notion that there is some
partizan holy position
that they're taking
in, that they're going
to fight this battle
a matter of principle
when they enact the tax cuts
for the wealthiest people of America
during the Trump administration,
they added
dramatically to the national debt,
which we are now facing.
Having done that,
they need to face the responsibility
of paying for it.
That is what the debt limit is about.
And if we play games with this,
if we delay this, if we have short term
extensions of the national debt,
we run the very risk of a recession
in this economy.
Millions of Americans
out of work and interest rates going
even higher.
Denying people
an opportunity
to buy
a home or car in this economy
will be stalled.
We shouldn't play games
with the national debt.
When Joe Biden was vice president.
I'm sure you remember
back in 2011,
he was the lead
negotiator on negotiations
for spending cuts
in exchange for raising the debt ceiling.
But you think you're saying
you think it's different
because of what happened
during the Trump years
I think it's different.
Not just because the Trump here
is being the origin of much of this debt
but by the new House of Representatives.
15 ballots down that you were there
you saw it
or at least witnessed on television
15 ballots to choose the speaker
and he gave the authority
to each member of the House
to initiate a vote
of no confidence on a daily basis.
I mean,
this is a House of Representatives which
is under control of the mega
Republicans at this point.
And I'm fearful
that very few constructive
things will emerge.
Before I let you go.
I have to ask about the Supreme Court.
You are, of course,
Senate Judiciary chairman.
You saw what happened at the court.
They announced this week
that they were unable
to determine
who leaked the draft decision overturning
Roe versus Wade last year.
Clerks
and employees had to sign sworn affidavit
saying that they didn't leak
the draft opinion.
The justices,
neither the justices
nor their spouses
actually had to sign affidavits
So do you believe that
that was a mistake?
Should they have to do
so to figure out where the leak
came from?
Listen, the universe of people
who are suspects
in this
leak of the opinion of the Supreme Court
is really a small universe.
It includes the justices
and their families.
If they had access to this opinion,
which I assume some of them did.
They should have gone into the least
the position of assertions
by each one of the justices
as to what they did
or did not do
when it came to these opinions.
But I find it hard to imagine with this
small group of people who had access
to this opinion,
they couldn't come up
with more information.
Are you going to try, in your capacity
as judiciary chair
No, I don't think this is an area
where we can go in with any kind of force
and make four changes result
at this point.
Okay.
Senate Judiciary Chairman
Dick Durbin, thank you so much.
And I should say the Senate whip.
Thank you so much for joining me
this morning. Appreciate it.